have you ever had
had been at a bitch's house and then
like her significant other pull up
nah i don't been at a girl house though
and her dad
her dad pulled up because you know i'm
still young right right
right feel me but this happened like two
years ago she'd be piping like a little
17 18 year old when you're like
17 18. nah when i was when i turned 18
that was the cutoff line no i mean like
maybe when you were when you were seven
years old and i was 17 yeah yeah yeah
but i was 18
though at the time so you know at 18
people people stood up with their
parents of course so shorty was 18 i'm
18. i'm
thinking her [ __ ] i'm talking
about [ __ ]
[ __ ] so i so i i got around the bed like
we in a pitch dark
me and her laying in the bed [ __ ]
my producer and [ __ ]
another girl laying on the on the ground
like her
and like yo they so boom me and shorty
on the bed my producer and another
shorty on the ground like they laying on
a bed
clearly a one-bedroom house yeah facts
i'm like i'm like so boom right i'm on a
bed piping or like it's
mad quiet in here but the shorty ass on
the ground got a son
her son is in there in the room while
you're piping my producer ruthless
he piping shorty while her son is
like how old is her son like three
oh so he's like he could walk what he
knew what was going on he had to know
what was going on
oh piping her i'm talking about boom
next thing i know [ __ ] he leaves out the
house like
it's time for a little boy no no your
producer my producer
leave out the house it's time for us to
go he leave out the house her dad
wake up her dad wakes up and comes in a
room
i'm hiding under the bed like i'm
talking about he cut the light on and
everything like
what's going on in here like would you
yo i'm like yo
bro hey and i swear i lied to
not i had to be like in in like gang man
like i had to be like in like the
hispanic territory like i was in the
wrong territory i lied to not like the
corner stores was still open it was like
two in the morning so he was piping a
latina
i ain't gonna say that you know those
latin fathers are crazy
i did
i mean my wife's mexican uh my baby mom
is mexican hey
protect me well you know the interview
no the the the
you know hey man that's one thing i'm
scared of is a mexican father bro
nah real talk that's what i'm saying
like yeah i'm talking about yo
like where we was at like it was
machetes on the ground oh
[ __ ] yeah like spring where's the
three-year-old by the way at this point
man under the bed with you no oh no
like hiding
yo you know kids like talk
so i'm so glad he didn't say nothing
because like
what if he was like grandpa he under the
bed
oh man i'll be there right now you might
be no energy
you did you know that her dad was asleep
when you was piping
yeah so you was in there like yo look we
gonna sneak in the shorties crib
me and the homie thanks
be quiet we go keep the kid in here i
i don't yo listen i'm gonna keep him
steady
he more messed up to me because i know
that kid's [ __ ] now because he
witnessed his mom getting
getting rolled on and then her homie
getting rolled on x
no no no her cut yeah whatever it was
but i'm talking about he's gonna grow a
buck wild bro i'm piping her
piping her did he like did you like
chuck the dude's like what's a little
man just no
it was pitch black did you pass in my
ipad it was pitch black he was on the
phone no he was on the phone
yeah that's what you got to do yes but
exactly oh you got the right idea yo
here's my here's my phone what games you
like
it was angry birds youtube it was dumb
late at night like ryan's toy review
go over there and i'm gonna [ __ ] yeah
yeah facts
she was getting piped though well i'm
glad that you're still here man i'm glad
that that that that
i'm heading to the store because like
i'm telling you when i when i
when i walked to that corner store and i
seen the corner store was still open and
the autumn people was outside the corner
store
i'm like i'm definitely dumb